china lidia con la peor crisis de
corralillos desde los tiempos de wuhan
no es un titular nuevo pero lo que varía
es la magnitud porque los anteriores re
procesos más inquietantes se habían
saldado con centenarios de casos diarios
y el martes en cambio se superaron los
5.000 más de 40 millones de personas
están confinadas en ciudades como
shenzhen la macrourbe del sur shangai el
corazón financiero o chanchung la
capital de la provincia nororiental de
jilín que concentra más de la mitad de
los casos sus habitantes no pueden salir
de los límites provinciales una medida
inédita desde que se tomara conjuve y
hace más de dos años preocupa los
efectos de este rebrote para las cadenas
de suministro globales por que se
nieguen cuenta con el cuarto puerto más
grande del mundo y multinacionales como
toyota volkswagen o apple han tenido que
cerrar algunas de sus plantas la
variante o micro on la más contagiosa de
todas se está poniendo a prueba la
eficacia de la política de 'tolerancia
cero' muchas voces desde pero piden a
china que la jubile aludiendo a casi el
90 de la población que tiene ya las
pausas la pauta completa de vacunación
algunos estudios científicos internos
por el contrario revelan que si china
aflojar a sus medidas la pandemia se
cobraría un número de vidas diarias que
sería de difícil digestión tanto para el
gobierno como para la sociedad